the 5th wave stars Chloe grace Moretz
and is a story of a world that has been
overrun by aliens referred to as others
certain waves have occurred these waves
have knocked out various things that
humans need to survive like power and
there are select few amount of survivors
left and one of them is Chloe grace
Moretz and she is trying to get to her
brother who's been taken to an army base
this movie started out surprisingly not
too bad the first act of this movie I
was slightly invested there was too much
narration and a lot of exposition where
people just stand around and say the
plot and let us know what things are but
for the most part the first act of this
movie I actually thought was a little
bit better than I was expecting going in
and then one point it was almost like
they just gave up and the movie turns
into another young person in some sort
of dystopian world trying to run from
some unknown force and there's a love
triangle - yes I was hoping for that
honestly for the first maybe half hours
so I was thinking to myself you know
this isn't too bad I'm a little bit
pleasantly surprised
the director seemed like he was actually
trying to make some good scenes it some
of it actually felt investing some of
the visuals were a little questionable
but it was like it wasn't like a big
problem in the movie just drops off the
map entirely and becomes a very boring
film with our hero played by Chloe grace
Moretz running into a boy in the middle
of the woods who she observes while he
bathes and he's really muscular he's
rubbing water all over his muscles and
it's just like what happened this was
kind of compelling and then it just went
it was almost like somebody came along
with a kind of cool story idea and then
they just said hey let's just make it
conventional and like everything else
yeah okay yeah
chi-ching and as the movie went along it
just got worse and worse the only way
you learn about this alien force is this
army captain played by Liev Schreiber
going here's all of the information this
is what we know and I just want you to
know that Oh an audience if you're
listening I hope you are because you
need to know this this this is this this
got it good now we have a story update
it's exactly like that and it's very
poor storytelling I was very
disappointed in the way the 5th wave
concluded and basically the entire sec
and third act it just becomes the exact
same thing we've been seeing in so many
different movies what started out as a
somewhat compelling alien invasion
thriller turned into another why a
dystopian novel turned movie and it was
very disappointing I'm gonna give the
5th wave a d-plus this movie was wasted
potential that could have done so much
more with this story but they just chose
the straight easy path that all of these
movies have been taken over the past few
years so guys you may have noticed that
behind me is a bunch of Tomb Raider
merchandise well that's because I just
filmed my hilarious 'ti review of Tomb
Raider and oh my gosh I had so much fun
that's going to go up on Sunday I can't
wait to share that with you it's my
biggest guilty pleasure movie of all
time guys look forward to that thank you
so much for watching and if you like
this you can click right here and get
stuck mine eyes